[Music]
jonathan is with us in coeur d'alene
idaho hi jonathan welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave hey what's up
well um unfortunately my uncle passed
away earlier this week oh my god
sorry i'm a little nervous here it's
okay i'm sorry to hear that were you
close yeah
yeah i was feeling like a dad to me
oh man
going through his paperwork and his will
it looks like uh he left me
quite a bit in his estate um
total amount looks like it's probably
gonna be over half a million dollars not
exactly sure what to do with it
in cash or in what
uh real estate a home that's worth about
400 that he owned outright and then the
rest is i haven't figured out exactly
how much it is but it's at least 100 000
in checking account a pension
and another retirement account
what do you make a year
about 65. how old are you 33. okay you
ever handled anything like an estate
before
i had with my mom but it was uh
valued at probably about a hundred
thousand so it's obviously a lot less
than this okay
so are you uh you found the will then
yes okay so you've been appointed the
executor of the estate
correct and you are the only heir
correct okay
so
my advice first would be to contact a
good estate
probate attorney to probate the will and
get you put in charge of each of these
accounts as soon as possible by the
court
okay and we actually did start the
process on that but we still have to
wait for the death certificate
unfortunately it takes a little time but
i'm glad to know you're already doing
that good okay and uh well
the emotion is real
and obviously you know you guys were
close he was like a dad to you and
he was obviously loved you a lot he left
you everything
and so what do you do with
500 000
when it's set in the middle of your
kitchen table all of a sudden in 100
bills what do you do with that
well obviously we want to be wise with
it
um
overall there's three things you can do
with money you can give it
you can enjoy it
and you can invest it
and those are the three things you can
do and you really probably should do all
three of those things with this money
now we teach a thing called the baby
steps and so
my son is about your age if he inherited
that all of a sudden i would advise him
and he would already know
because he's my son to walk right up the
baby steps with that money and um you
know where would that take you are you
aware of all of that
yeah so i actually have no debt other
than my house which you owe how much on
them
uh 159 so i was planning on writing a
check for that pretty soon after
everything's closed okay um then that
puts you at what we call baby step seven
where there's nothing left to do but
build wealth and be generous you
remember that does that sound familiar
to you
yes
okay
jonathan that's an incredible place to
be but i know it doesn't feel like it
right now
yeah i know you're you're hurting um i
think it's awesome that you're calling
and you're getting
wise counsel on what to do with this
large amount of money
you're already taking the right steps
you've already handled this before it
may have been a different amount of
money but you've gone through this and
so i want you to lean on those skills
and let that give you a sense of
peace and confidence as you as you walk
this out again
and then know as you do
yeah you're in a really good position
financially to do
anything you want to you're young to
have this what a gift
that your uncle left you at your young
age you'll never have debt again
ever
i mean that's an incredible gift and
legacy
that he gave you
and um and i know you're hurting right
now and it's hard to even feel that and
that's okay too that's okay so one of
the things i try to do um
that i have done gradually i never got a
uh
in the early days anyway i never got a
half million dollar check at one time
come into my life but
what i did gradually is i increased my
knowledge
uh by putting experts in my corner to
teach me and that's kind of where we
came up with the saying with endorsed
local providers or with smart investor
pros when you're meeting with people in
the money space you need someone with
the heart of a teacher
not someone to boss you around and
because i hate it when people say well i
couldn't buy a car my advisor told me i
couldn't
i'm like it's not your advisor's money
you doob
it's your money
you tell your advisor what to do they
just give you advice
um and so that's just a cop out meaning
i don't have enough so i want you to
have enough backbone to make your own
decisions
as opposed to that person i just
outlined but i want you to put some
advisors some teachers
in your corner
and so you know you do need to meet with
a smart vester pro
and learn about some investing options
um
what are your thoughts on the house you
you uh it probably not going to keep it
if you want to keep it as a rental you
can
i i think it's gonna be troublesome uh i
don't know if you're gonna have the
money with everything you've outlined to
completely pay your house off unless you
keep it number two when you run out your
uncle's house and a renter doesn't take
care of it one time that's going to be
very very very emotional
um people don't realize that like when
you move out of a house that you lived
in and then you rent it out it's a
it's
renters are even the best people in the
world including when i was a renter it's
not your house and it's just a weird
feeling to go back in there and go oh
look what they did to them
my little boy's bedroom you know it just
does that to you you can't keep yourself
from doing that so i doubt you're going
to keep it if you want to fight to keep
it that's fine as a rental
i wouldn't keep it sitting there empty
as a museum to your uncle i think that's
a bad idea
but so you need a good insurance person
in your corner that's an independent
insurance broker that can help you with
all the different kinds of insurance you
need in your life you need a good
investing professional in your corner
that you know like a smart investor pro
that it has the heart of a teacher and
will lead you in each of those areas you
need a good tax person a cpa in this
case you've already engaged a lawyer to
help you with the process so all of
these different experts in these
different areas are to teach you
something about
that area so that you can make good
decisions
they're not there to boss you around
they actually work for you you're paying
them and so they need to keep that
in mind i've had to fire a couple people
in the professions over the years that
decided their job was to tell me what to
do with my life instead their job is to
teach me and then i get to decide what
i'm going to do based on that knowledge
with my life they must not have known
you very well well i mean i know that
would not fly
no that's probably true but i mean i i
remember you know uh
well it's just it doesn't matter but the
the uh an attorney one time that was
just telling us that this is the way
this has to be and i said no it doesn't
have to be that way i'm not doing it and
he goes well you know that that you know
and he just the arrogance of it and
finally i just said look i think we're i
think we're done what do you mean we're
done i said i think you're fired
because i'm not gonna i'm not here for
you to tell me what to do i'm here for
you to teach me
and convince me
that this is the wisest and in the
multitude of council there is safety and
that's what you want you want to
a group of counsel in your life that'll
walk with you through this jonathan and
teach you
and that'll help you keep from making
unwise decisions
and
and of course the overall arching rule
is don't take financial advice from
broke people including your broke
friends and they all have a lot of
opinions right now